we have one question from Swati from
Mumbai posted in our Facebook and the
question is what is one thing in 2012
you would like to see happen in the
world it's a great question um in 2012
who like to see in a stronger commitment
of world leaders to shape in a better
world map can be supplied three things
one of them is that national aboriginal
institutions particularly public
institutions show a better commitment in
including the voices of the of the
excluded in other words more democracy
number two I would expect a changing
consumption behaviour in terms of relief
society in general paying more attention
to the depletion of the environment and
finally a determination to an extreme
poverty in fact in many of the panels
here the world economic forum in davos
we realize that it is possible to an
extreme for it you'd only request a
stronger commitment so thank you for
your question